so uh we are getting pretty strong
indications of the result
uh we believe that uh tori uh the mps
voted by 291
to 78 in favor of boris johnson's plan
uh now it looks as if first of all it's
important to say boris johnson's tiering
system has become law restrictions will
be eased in the
uh in accordance with the tiers tomorrow
uh when those uh when those changes come
in they are now
uh that is now um uh a certainty
uh 291 uh mps uh voting in favor now
remember i said that 364 tory mps were
being asked by boris johnson
uh to vote for it so it looks at the
moment as if 56
there or thereabout conservative mps
voted
against the prime minister's uh
proposition the tiering proposition now
that is a significantly higher
number than the 34 that voted to go into
lockdown two
and the 42 that voted
that voted against the curfew which is
the biggest rebellion of the parliament
to date uh remember the ten o'clock
curfew which was unpopular with many
uh with many tory mps but if that figure
uh uh 56
uh tories proves to be correct it will
be the biggest rebellion of this
parliament and significantly higher
than the last one and you've clearly got
uh dozens of other conservative mps on
top of that
abstaining over on the labor side the
rebel there is a rebellion it's largely
from the left of the party
uh voting for a zero covered approach as
they would put it
it looks as if there are 16 labour mps
who oppose the tiering system so
a very significant defeat uh a very
significant rebellion
for boris johnson tonight but because of
the decision
uh by the opposition parties to abstain
it nevertheless goes through
uh and it just intensifies the
unhappiness i suspect on the
conservative ventures
sam's figures are pretty accurate i can
confirm it's 16 labor rebels
which makes round about 56 conservatives
we know that the likes of sammy wilson
and probably a handful
of the dup will have voted against so
219 to
78 now some drama from inside the
chamber because i'm told
by mps who've just voted that the prime
minister
was standing at the door of the eye
lobby begging
tory mps to vote with the government
well obviously
a number of them did but clearly many of
those pleas
fell on deaf ears this of course
followed a
zoom call to tory mps at six o'clock in
another 11th hour
plea to get tory mps to vote for the gut
for the measure
real desperation on the part of the
prime minister of course he'd staked his
authority on this
his whole authority has been questioned
by some of his own side now
so in the past hour we've seen the prime
minister an emergency
zoom call to tory mps begging them to
vote with him
and then as the vote was taking place
the pm
standing at the door of the eye lobby
begging conservative mps to vote with
him
well it looks like 56 57 58 have
defied him and gone into the other lobby
along with
eight uh 16 labour mps smaller rebellion
on the labor side
comfortable majority obviously but real
drama behind the scenes here
inside the lobbies with the pm
desperately appealing to tory mps to
back him
john thank you uh sam you've had a
statement from the government in the
last few moments uh
number 10 have responded a government
spokesman says we welcome tonight's vote
which endorses our winter plan brings to
an end the national restrictions and
returns england to a tiered system this
will help safeguard the gains
made during the past month and keep the
virus under control we'll continue to
work with mps
who have expressed concerns in recent
days